Live long and prosper.
Is there a more famous TV gesture than the Vulcan salute?
Leonard Nimoy, who popularized the gesture in his role as Mr. Spock...
...on the 60s TV series Star Trek, both lived long and prospered...
...before dying at the age of 83.
In an age where the word is overused,...
...a half man, half alien was truly an iconic character:...
...pointy ears, upturned eyebrows, bowl haircut,...
...maddeningly logical, frustratingly dispassionate.
You'd make a splendid computer, Mr. Spock.
He and his fellow Star Trek crew would go on to star...
...in the first of six feature films based on the series, two of which Nimoy directed.
Anyone who's ever been defined by a single accomplishment...
...can understand why Nimoy was at points ambivalent about his legacy.
This was a man who wrote two autobiographies and cheekily titled them...
..."I Am Not Spock" and "I Am Spock."
He appeared in both the Star Trek reboot and its sequel...
...and happily attended fan convention after fan convention.
To paraphrase one of the franchise's most famous, and come on, moving scenes,...
...Leonard Nimoy was and always will be Mr. Spock.
Live long and prosper.